which are three bands who've been
holding out the info on the two upcoming
expansion packs will be happy to hear
that a prize has been announced
developers to the project red have
concerned that the hearts of stone as
well as the blood and wine expansion
packs will be contained within the games
$25 expansion class nothing has been
confirmed as to whether or not the
expansion packs will be sold separately
heart of stone is due out in October of
this year well blood and wine will be
out in early 2016 these expansions are
slated to add about 30 hours of gameplay
to the allegedly 200 plus our game if
you're really early keen to play the
main story though it's still going to
take you awhile set a project red reveal
that the fastest any of their testers
could complete the RPGs story for 25
hours that's with the player ignoring
all side quests and skipping through
dialogue let me know down in the
comments if you think 25 bucks is a fair
price for the witcher 3 expansion past
or not and why we'll keep you updated on
all the latest in girls adventures so
stay tuned to GameSpot's